>>> WELCOME BACK.
POLAND'S EDUCATION MINISTER SAYS
HIS NATION SHOULD COPY HUNGARY'S
CONTROVERSIAL LAW THAT BANS
SCHOOLS FROM TEACHING ANYTHING
ABOUT HOMOSEXUALITY.
THE RECENTLY PASSED HUNGARIAN
LAW HAS BEEN MET BY OUTRAGE IN
MUCH OF WESTERN EUROPE, BUT SOME
CONSERVATIVE POLITICIANS ARE
PRAISING IT.
HERE'S MORE FROM ISA SOARES.
>> Reporter: ON THE BANKS OF THE
DANUBE RIVER, THE STRIKING
HUNGARIAN PARLIAMENT WAS BUILT.
THE BILL WHICH ERODES GAY RIGHTS
IN THE COUNTRY, WHERE THERE ARE
ALREADY PRECIOUS FEW, PASSED
WITH ALMOST NO OBJECTIONS INSIDE
THE CHAMBER BUT PLENTY OUTSIDE.
LAST WEEK PROTESTERS FILL THE
STREETS OF BUDAPEST TO RALLY
AGAINST THE BILL JUST SIGNED
INTO LAW BY PRIME MINISTER
VIKTOR ORBAN.
GENDER ALTERATION OR
HOMOSEXUALITY, EFFECTIVELY
BARRING ANY DISCUSSION ON THE
TOPIC INSIDE CLASSROOMS OR EVEN
IN ADVERTISING.
LIKE THIS 2019 COKE AD WHICH WAS
CONTROVERSIAL IN HUNGARY.
THIS WAS ALL ADDED TO A BILL
MEANT TO BETTER PROTECT CHILDREN
FROM PEDOPHILES, MAKING IT
DIFFICULT FOR LAWMAKERS TO VOTE
AGAINST IT.
OPPOSITION PARTIES BOYCOTTED THE
VOTE.
>> Translator: TO MIX UP
HOMOSEXUALITY WITH SEXUAL CRIMES
IS DISGUSTING.
>> Translator: EACH ABUSED CHILD
WHO FEARS ASKING FOR HELP
BECAUSE OF HOMOPHOBIC OR
TRANSPHOBIC HATRED WILL SUFFER.
>> Reporter: PRIME MINISTER
ORBAN SIMPLY STATES CLEARLY THAT
ONLY PARENTS CAN DECIDE ON THE
SEXUAL EDUCATION OF THEIR
CHILDREN.
AND THE BAN DOES NOT PLACE
CONTENT ADULTS CAN CONSUME.
NOT ONE WHICH HIDES IT FROM OUR
CHILDREN.
THE GOVERNMENT SAYS IT'S NOT
GOING TO APOLOGIZE FOR
PROTECTING OUR CHILDREN, AND
ORBAN HIMSELF INSISTS IT
REINFORCES A CENTRAL EUROPEAN
CONVICTION THAT TODAY'S LIBERALS
ARE IN FACT COMMUNISTS WITH
DEGREES.
>> I THINK IT'S A CONTINUATION
OF WHAT WE'VE SEEN IN THE PAST.
THIS IS STRAIGHT OUT OF AN
AUTOCRATS PLAYBOOK.
IT'S PART AND PARCEL OF THE
EROSION OF THE RULE OF LAW AND
THE SUSTAINED ATTACK IN HUNGARY.
>> GAY PEOPLE IN HUNGARY CAN
ALREADY NOT MARRY OR ADOPT
CHILDREN.
LAST YEAR SOME POLISH TOWNS
DECLARED THEMSELVES LGBT
IDEOLOGY FREE ZONE.
>> IN RUSSIA WE HAD GROUPS THAT
BILLED THEMSELVES AS
ANTI-PEDOPHILE GROUPS WHO
TARGETED YOUNG GAY MEN, WOULD
SUBJECT THEM TO HARASSMENT AND
TORTURE, FILM THAT, AND THEN
UPLOADED THAT ON TO SOCIAL
MEDIA.
I SUSPECT IT COULD HAVE GREATER
IMPLICATIONS THAN THE PROPAGANDA
LAW.
>> Reporter: LOOKING LESS AND
LESS LIKE THE REST OF EUROPE.
ISA SOARES, CNN LONDON.
>> I'M JOINED NOW BY ONE OF THE
LEADING POLITICIANS IN HUNGARY
CAMPAIGNING AGAINST THE
HOMOSEXUALITY LAW.
SHE PLANS TO RUN AGAINST THE
HUNGARIAN PRIME MINISTER VIKTOR
ORBAN IN NEXT YEAR'S ELECTIONS
AND JOINS US LIVE.
THANKS SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME.
>> THANK YOU FOR THE INVITATION.
>> SO, THIS BILL WAS SIGNED INTO
PARLIAMENT LAST WEEK.
IT'S BEEN WIDELY CONDEMNED BY
HUMAN RIGHTS ORGANIZATIONS.
YOU'VE CONDEMNED IT AS WELL.
JUST DESCRIBE HOW IT CAME ABOUT
AND WHY THERE WAS SO LITTLE
RESISTANCE AMONGST THOSE VOTING.
>> WELL, YOU HAVE TO UNDERSTAND
THAT THIS IS THE BASIC, THE
POLITICS OF ORBAN RULING THE
COUNTRY SINCE 2010, EVERY TIME
THERE IS AN ELECTION COMING HE
IS POINTING THE FINGER AT ONE OF
THE GROUPS OR ONE OF THE GROUPS
OF PEOPLE IN ORDER TO HATE THEM.
THIS BAN ON GAY AND LESBIAN
PEOPLE, THE LGBTQ COMMUNITY,
FOUR YEARS AGO THERE WAS THE
MIGRANTS AND REFUGEES.
IN HUNGARY HE ALWAYS WANTS
PEOPLE TO HATE SOMEONE IN ORDER
TO DIVERT THE TIDE OF THE
POLITICS OR THE TOPIC OF THE
POLITICS FROM THE REAL
PERFORMANCE.
>> THERE'S A GREAT DEAL OF
BACKLASH IN EUROPE OVER THIS
LAW.
SOME EUROPEAN LEADERS SAY
HUNGARY SHOULD LEAVE EUROPE
BECAUSE THIS LAW DOESN'T FIT --
BECAUSE IT DOESN'T FIT IN WITH
EUROPE'S IDEALS.
THE DUTCH PM EVEN SUGGESTED THAT
HUNGARY'S PRIME MINISTER SHOULD
TRIGGER ARTICLE 50 TO LEAVE.
YOU SAID THIS COULD BE A TURNING
POINT.
JUST EXPLAIN WHY.
>> YES.
VIKTOR ORBAN MADE A LOT OF STEPS
IN THE LAST TEN YEARS IN ORDER
TO WEED OUT HUNGARY.
THE REASON FOR HIM TO STAY IN
THE UNION ARE THE EU FUNDS,
NECESSITIES FOR EUROPEAN UNION
EVERY YEAR.
BUT NOW WITH THE NEW REGULATION,
IT CAN BE STOPPED ESPECIALLY
WHEN THE GOVERNMENTS LIKE THE
HUNGARIAN GOVERNMENT IS SIMPLY
NOT OBEYING WITH THE RULE OF LAW
OR WITH HUMAN RIGHTS AS IS THE
CASE.
SO, TINY REASON FOR HIM IN ORDER
TO ACCEPT THE EUROPEAN UNION'S
REGULATION IS GOING AWAY.
AND IT'S CLEAR THAT HIS FOCUS,
HIS POLITICAL FOCUS IS NOT
TOWARDS RUSSIA, TOWARDS CHINA,
TOWARDS TURKEY AND NOT TOWARDS
THE BEST DEMOCRACIES.
THAT IS THE REASON WHY THE
OPPOSITION UNITED ITSELF IN
ORDER TO REALLY PUT AN END TO
THIS NIGHTMARE.
>> I'M HAVING A LITTLE BIT OF
DIFFICULT WITH THE AUDIO, BUT I
JUST WANT TO ASK YOU A LITTLE
BIT MORE ABOUT THAT.
SO, SIX OPPOSITION PARTIES ARE
UNITING TO RUN TO DEFEAT PRIME
MINISTER ORBAN IN THE NEXT
ELECTION.
THIS IS A HUGE MOMENT.
DO YOU THINK THIS IS YOUR ONLY
WAY TO DEFEAT THE PRIME
MINISTER?
>> YES, DEFINITELY.
YOU HAVE TO UNDERSTAND THAT THE
FIRST STEP OF ORBAN IN 2010,
BACK IN 2010, IS TO CHANGE THE
ELECTION AND TO CHANGE IT IN A
UNILATERAL WAY.
SO, WITHOUT DISCUSSING IT WITH
ANYONE.
SO, WE KNOW EXACTLY THAT THE
ELECTION IS GOING TO BE FREE AND
FAIR.
BUT STILL THE DIFFERENT PARTIES,
LIBERAL, SOCIAL, DEMOCRATS,
CONSERVATIVES, UNITED THEMSELVES
TOGETHER BECAUSE THIS IS THE
ONLY WAY WE CAN REALLY DEFEAT
ORBAN.
AND NOW THE UNITED OPPOSITION IS
LEADING BY SEVERAL PERCENT,
ACCORDING TO THE POLLS.
THAT MEANS THAT WE ARE GOING TO
MAKE SOME PRIMARIES.
WHILE IT'S NOT EXACTLY THE SAME
LIKE IN THE UNITED STATES
BECAUSE IT'S NOT GOING TO BE A
PRIMARY LIKE WE DID IN THE
DEMOCRAT, BUT THIS IS GOING TO
BE A PRIMARY AMONG PARTIES IN
ORDER TO CHOOSE ONE PRIME
MINISTER CANDIDATE FOR EVERY
CONSTITUENCY.
AND THIS IS THE WAY TECHNICALLY
HOW WE CAN DEFEAT ORBAN.
AND I REALLY FEEL THE POWER OF
THE PEOPLE.
I THINK THE HUGE MAJORITY OF THE
HUNGARIANS ARE SIMPLY FED UP
WITH ORBAN AND HIS GOVERNMENT.
>> ALL RIG